primero cuéntenos de la planta nuclear
porque es importante que el oiea visite
la planta y cuál es el riesgo para
ucrania y para europa de que sigan los
combates alrededor
un gusto saludar de manera clara y clara
y me parece importante resaltar que este
organismo multilateral se encarga entre
muchas otras funciones pues de hacer
toda una revisión para poder ver los
daños ocasionados por este bombardeo más
allá de 100 de un lado o del otro lado
hay riesgos por todo lo que esto implica
a las comunidades cercanas
de sap orilla entonces estamos viendo
que el hecho de que no se permita una
revisión técnica que nada tiene que ver
con la parte política ni ni de la guerra
es importante que se haga si no se
permite pues entonces no se van a poder
evaluar los daños y las consecuencias
estamos viendo ahorita que se está
hablando de esta planta nuclear pero ya
en el pasado en la coyuntura de esta
guerra ya hemos visto los ataques los
bombardeos a otras plantas nucleares
marie anne clark entonces estos son muy
malas noticias
y como tal son también muy malas
noticias el tema del referéndum no o sea
ahorita la coyuntura actual manera clara
es la tormenta perfecta
para vladimir putin de lo que se está
suscitando en taiwán donde todo el foco
de atención internacional
estable esta isla y no en lo que está
sucediendo que nos ocupa desde las
entidades atrás en un crack y
precisamente a propósito de estos
referendos en esa orilla y en gerzón que
usted menciona ya rusia había adelantado
una estrategia similar en crimea el
territorio que se anexaron en 2014 con
qué nivel de coacción se realizan estos
procesos que ya son costumbre para rusia
totalmente que parece que está
estrategia del año 2014 lo quiere
replicar ahora a vladimir putin pero me
parece que las circunstancias han
cambiado el mundo ha cambiado y yo creo
que la población de crimea en este
momento quisiera totalmente produce no
están 100% tan alineada ahora en estas
zonas de razón de esa polilla como como
lo fueron en primera entonces este tema
de éste manipuleo para cobijar y decir
que es un referéndum que surge desde la
población por supuesto que no es así la
población lo que no quiere es tener el
verdugo en casa y mucho menos que haya
una anexión entonces estamos viendo que
ahorita la estrategia de rusia es
intentar venderles lo mismo que él pasó
en el año 2014 pero el resultado no
puede ser el mismo y me parece que lejos
de avanzar hacia un proceso de paz
estable porque está sumando es encender
más ya de por sí está guerra
y fragmentar mucho la parte de la
sociedad